Mawson: So welcome, everybody,
to Google I/O.
First session of the morning.
My name is Sven Mawson.
I'm gonna be
talking to you about
some of the new stuff
we've been working on,
the Google Data Protocol.
I'm a member of
the Google Data APIs team.
So the thing
we're concerned with today
is how to build
more efficient applications.
How many of you guys
are familiar, first of all,
with the Google Data APIs
and have used them?
So a fair number, okay.
For those you that haven't,
I'm gonna give
a quick background.
The Google Data APIs
are a set of APIs
that are based
on some common standards
like AtomPub,
Atom Publishing Protocol
and Atom.
And then RSS,
we also support.
And we support some JSON.
This set of APIs is supported
by many, many Google services,
including YouTube,
Picasa Web Albums,
Calendar, Docs,
et cetera.
There's many, many of them.
You can find
the whole list at
code.google.com/apis/gdata.
So for more information
on that.
So the sort of
starter question is:
what kind of applications
are we talking about
that we're worried
about efficiency?
Well, of course the answer
is every application
should be worried
about efficiency, right?
Everything costs money,
so the faster
the application is,
the more users you'll get,
the more your users
will be happy,
you know, the more money
you'll save on bandwidth.
All kinds of stuff.
So within that,
there actually are
some sets of applications
that this matters
even more than others.
For example,
mobile applications
really, really need efficiency
because they're limited
by their bandwidth,
they're limited by latency,
they're limited by the memory
on the client.
So everything
really matters there.
And AJAX applications
in general
are also very sensitive
to efficiency.
So what kind of things
can we do
to make them more efficient?
The first thing we can do,
of course,
is to reduce
the number of requests.
So the less round trips
you make to the server,
the faster your application's
gonna be.
Another thing you can do
is to reduce the bandwidth.
The less wire size
your requests are taking,
the quicker the server
will be able to respond,
the quicker your application
will work,
the less money your users
will spend on bandwidth,
if they're mobile users
and they actually pay
for bandwidth,
and the less money
you'll pay for bandwidth
if you're using,
for example, App Engine,
and you pay by bandwidth.
So bandwidth
is very important.
And of course latency
is also very important.
So reducing the amount of time
between making a request
and getting a response back.
Any way you can reduce that,
your users will be happy,
and you'll be happy.
Okay, so I'm gonna show
a quick little demo
of something I built called
Photo Shuffle.
It's a very, very simple
App Engine app
on photoshuffle.appspot.com
if you want to look at it.
The source is actually
just an HTML page.
So if you want
to get the source,
just go to it and view source,
and there it is.
It doesn't use
anything exciting,
so here it is.
It asks for a username
in the Picasa Web Album
service.
So I'm gonna use a username
I created for today.
And click Load Albums,
and it loads up all your albums
from Picasa Web Albums
using the Google Data API.
This is actually running--
This version is running
using all the stuff
I'm gonna talk about today.
So it's actually pretty fast.
If it was not running
with the stuff
I'm talking about today,
it would be a bit slower.
But for example, this
photos from Yosemite album
is I think 500 photos.
So you can see
it loaded all of these
very, very quickly.
And that's all because
of the stuff
I'm gonna talk about today.
So the application is called
Photo Shuffle
because I added this button
that lets you shuffle.
So it just
moves the photos around.
Not very exciting,
but it's,
you know, it's an AJAX app.
It loads data using
the APIs.
It does what
it's supposed to do.
You know, you can load up
a different album.
It'll shuffle those.
This is from
the tour of California
that was in the area
recently.
Okay, so that's
the little demo application.
Let's quickly take
a look back
at sort of what
the Google Data APIs
had before this.
So how many of you guys
have used the JSON output
of the Google Data APIs
that we have right now?
So a fair number,
but, you know,
maybe that was a sixth,
a seventh.
Not too many.
Okay.
So a quick background.
The way we set up
our JSON output
was as a direct translation
of the XML.
So this is an XML to JSON
back to XML
translation conversion.
And the reason we did this
is for read-write support.
So if you have
an Atom Publishing Protocol API
like the Google Data APIs,
you support full round-trips
of reading data,
modifying it, and writing it
back to the server.
Instead of having to support
parsing of the JSON,
all we support
is outputting JSON,
and then on the client
we can convert that JSON
back to XML and send that
back to the server
for an update.
So that's why we did things
the way we did it.
Although it's not that great.
So here's an example
of a conversion.
See the XML on the left,
the JSON on the right.
It looks very, very similar.
We just replaced things
around a little bit.
You know,
there's the media content.
It's easy to see
how you can convert
back and forth
between them.
So what we did
is any XML element,
we just take and turn it
directly into a JSON object.
So there are the elements.
Every single one
is an object
in our current JSON format.
It's pretty inefficient.
Attributes
are a little bit nicer.
They're just JSON properties.
So we have an attribute
like the url,
the type, medium.
Those are all translated
directly across.
And then when you send it
off to the server,
it's translated back
the other direction.
So it's very simple.
The other thing we had to do
is because in XML you have--
you have attributes
and you have elements,
but the elements themselves
also have content.
So elements can have content
and attributes
and child elements,
although the combination
isn't really supported.
But so what we had to do
is whenever you have
text content,
we had to have
a special property called $t
that stores
the text content then.
So here's an example
of the media credit.
The content of that element
is a property
on the media credit object
called $t.
So it's a direct translation.
It's about the same size.
It's not that exciting.
So this is what
that Photo Shuffle application
looks like when you're
using that JSON.
So that application
I just showed,
this is the code from it.
This is how you would load up
data using a script tag.
So how many people
are familiar
with using script tags
for loading data?
Okay, so that's more than
have used our JSON.
Anyway, this is what you do.
You create a script tag.
You stick it in the head.
You set the source of it
to your script source.
In this case, we're using
the Picasa Web Albums
data API
with the username
that I typed into that box.
And then I'm getting
the JSON alt format.
And the callback
I just called "callback"
for simplicity.
So here's that callback.
This is what--so what happens
is you load that script.
It goes to the server,
gets the data.
it comes back,
And that callback gets called
with your data.
So this callback
will get called with it.
We have to pull out
the albums from it,
which are in
data.feed.entry.
We loop through those,
and we call this method
addAlbum,
which we see here.
And here's where things
get kind of ugly.
To get the ID of the album,
we have to do
entry.gphoto$id.$t.
So that that $ notation
that we saw earlier
is actually for
XML namespace support.
So we actually have--
That gphoto is actually
an XML namespace alias,
and we include in the response
the XML namespaces.
And I'm gonna talk
about that a little bit more.
But there's a couple
important things here.
One is that to get
the feed link, which--
So the way that
the API is structured,
you get the albums.
And then each entry
in that feed
has a link to the list
of photos in that feed.
So that's that link there.
And it happens
to be the first link.
But the actual
right way to do this
would be to loop
through the links
looking for the one
with the rel value of feed
and pulling that one out
and getting its href.
But this is a lot easier
just to do an array index.
Of course it would break
if the server
ever returned things
in a different order.
But we know for a fact
that many people
have applications
coded this way,
so we actually
won't change the order.
But it's really not ideal
to do things this way,
and you probably shouldn't
if you were coding JSON.
But today I'm gonna announce
a much better way
to do this anyway, so...
The other sort of
thing to notice
is how long and ugly
that album thumbnail
sort of dereferencing is.
It's a media$group,
a media$thumbnail,
which is an array,
and then you have
to get the URL.
It's just kind of a pain.
So we need
to make this better.
So let's quickly
just go over
all of the reasons
why this isn't that great.
The first problem is you're
creating way too many objects.
This isn't as much
of a problem
on some of the modern browsers,
but older browsers
had huge problems
if you created a lot
of JavaScript objects.
So it's really good
to reduce those,
and a lot of people
still use those.
So we want to reduce that.
And it's really
not that great
that we're creating
all of these objects.
So in this example,
we have one, two, three, four,
five different objects.
And some of them just--
You know, the media credit,
all it has is a $t
with a credit in there.
It's not very exciting.
There's--
You know, it doesn't look
like there should be
a reason to actually do that,
but because we had to do
a complete XML to JSON
and back again,
that was necessitated.
So another problem
is of course--
I touched on this earlier--
how ugly that programming was.
So, you know,
here's getting the ID.
Here's getting that image.
It's really not fun.
The other big problem
is that we send a lot of stuff
that really is
completely unnecessary.
So this is actually the JSON
even though we're sending things
that look like XML, right?
So this is like
the XML version,
XML encoding,
all the XML namespaces.
Do you really
need that stuff?
No, you don't,
but we send it anyway
just because that's--
you know,
it's a direct translation.
So it just, in the end,
takes up way too much space.
So here's the Atom and--
the Atom compared
to the JSON,
and you can see they're
actually exactly the same.
One thing to note on this,
if you're not using
gzip compression
on your request to the server
you should be,
because it's a factor
of about 20 there,
that it makes it
much, much smaller.
So first thing you should do,
make sure you're getting gzip
to request responses.
And if you're not,
find out why,
because it's huge.
But even when compressed,
they compress about the same.
So there's really
no difference there.
So we can do better
than that.
So now I want
to introduce something
called JSONC to you guys.
And this is a clean, compact,
and customizable JSON format.
So one of the goals
that we had
was to minimize the number
of JavaScript objects
to reduce that.
And there's many ways
that we do that.
One thing--We have sort of
a set of standard rules,
and then we can customize
beyond that.
But I'm gonna go over
the standard rules here.
The first is for things that
are simple, single elements--
and by that I mean an element
that just
has a single attribute
or that just
has text content
and is not repeating--
there's only one of them.
It's really easy
to translate that
into something much better
than we were doing.
So we were doing
the thing on the left there,
which is to create an object
and have a $t.
But why not just output it
directly as the credit
with the name?
I mean, much simpler.
So that's what we're doing.
And the reason
we can get away with this
is that we know
on the server that
that element will never
have additional attributes.
It will never have
foreign elements under it.
We know because we're
the ones writing the code
what it's going to have
and what it's not going to have.
So we can actually say,
"Okay, we can output this
as a property."
It's really simple.
So we do that for those
simple, single elements.
But what about
for complex elements,
elements that have
maybe a couple attributes
and a text content, right?
So we can actually get rid of
the object there too.
What we do is actually pull
the additional attributes up
next to the property.
So you have--Where before
you had a summary object
with text
and a type attribute,
now we have a summary
and a summary type.
So it's very simple.
It makes it much easier
to use.
It gets rid of an object,
and it saves space
on the wire.
So it's pretty nice.
Things get a little bit
more complicated
when you start talking
about repeating elements,
because in XML
when something repeats,
you just see multiple of them.
There's nothing exciting
there.
In JSON
when something repeats,
you have to actually wrap them
all in an array.
So you have to know
ahead of time
what is repeating
and what is not.
But of course, again,
we're on the server.
We know these things.
We can make some things
a little bit nicer.
So something like
this keywords element
where it only
has text content,
it doesn't have
anything else,
we can just create
a simple array for you.
So, you know, keywords,
Google, I/O,
exactly like you'd expect.
This is the kind of JSON
you probably want to use.
Much nicer.
What about when you have
complex repeating elements?
So this is where things
fall apart in this model.
You can't actually come up
with any
standard set of rules
where, you know,
you can automatically convert
these complex
repeating elements
into a nice JSON format.
So here's where
the customization comes in.
So for something
like the links element,
we actually completely
customize the output.
And this is what I was--
also what I was saying
about how using
that array notation is bad,
but we have something better.
So before,
you had an array of links,
and they each had
a bunch of attributes.
They had the rel value,
which tells you,
you know, the name of it.
And then they had a type,
which tells you
what the MIME type will be
and then they actually
had the href.
In this case, the edit link
on the feed we're looking at
will always be of type
application/atom+xml.
So actually
sending that to you
is completely useless.
We don't need to do that.
So we can just
throw that away.
And then the other thing
we can do is we can take
that rel value and actually
make that the name of the link,
rather than making there
be a property for that.
And then the href, we used
the value of that property.
So now we just have
a links object
with edit equals whatever.
And all of those other links
will show up
as named properties.
So to dereference it,
you just do links.edit,
rather than find the link
with the rel value of edit
and then get the href.
So it's much nicer.
And this is what we do for these
complex repeating elements.
And actually, we customized
some other things too.
So it's very customizable.
Here's a complete example.
You can see this is
the media group element
within an entry.
For example,
a Picasa Web Albums photo.
You have that media group.
It had a media content,
it had a media credit,
media description.
There were--
what did I say--
five objects?
Now there's just one object.
It just has a bunch
of properties.
You just do "entry.media.
whatever you want,"
and it's there.
Much nicer to use.
The other thing we can do
is actually get rid of
some more of that data
that wasn't useful.
So I talked about
that edit link
where the type was--
you know, we didn't need it.
So we can do the same
kinda thing in other places.
The content medium,
in this case, always image.
Throw that away.
A description type,
always plain.
Throw it away.
So we can make things
a lot easier.
Now we're down
to four properties,
one object.
Really simple to use.
Kind of what we want to do.
All right, so let's
see this in action.
Let's take a look
at that code that we had
for the Photo Shuffle
application,
and let's change it to use
this new JSON format.
So all you do is change
from alt=json
to alt=jsonc,
and then you're gonna
get that back.
Of course, the model
that you get back--
Those JSON objects
have changed,
so you have to go change
how you dereference that data.
So when we get
the result back,
rather than having
a wrapper element
and then the feed
and then the entries,
we got rid of that
wrapper element,
so it's just a feed
and its entries.
So rather than
data.feed.entry,
you'd just do data--
Well, you would do entry,
but we made it even nicer
and we actually named it
based on what it is.
It's albums.
So we named it albums.
So you just do data.albums.
The other thing that
gets into it a little bit more
is when you're actually
processing those albums.
As you can see
on the right there,
all the things are much
nicer to look at.
So before we had
the gphoto$id
with the namespaces
and the $t.
It's just entry.id.
The links,
as I mentioned before,
it's just links.feed.
And then the thumbnails
is also simpler.
It's media.thumbnails.
So things have gotten
a lot nicer to use.
And of course the bandwidth
has gone way down.
So you can see
in the uncompressed case,
the bandwidth's about half.
In the compressed case,
it's about 2/3.
And the uncompressed is actually
still important to look at,
because that's the memory
that's gonna be used
by the browser after
it decompresses the feed.
So that's actually
what it's gonna--
what the browser's gonna
be using for memory.
So that's also important.
It's good that we have
both of those going
much, much smaller.
Another thing we can look at
is the request time.
So how long did the request
actually take?
And this is actually
from my house
with a really slow
internet connection.
Not from here,
which you saw,
you know,
it took on the order
of maybe 600 milliseconds.
At my house, it takes
four seconds with the JSON.
With the JSONC,
it takes roughly 2 3/4 or so.
So the request is faster,
and the parsing time
is faster.
This is in Firefox 3,
which is actually
a pretty fast parser.
But even in that, you can see
there's an improvement.
On older browsers,
which I didn't actually
get a chance to test--
on something like IE 6
or Firefox 2,
this would be
even more significant
just 'cause they took
so much time to parse.
Okay, so that was JSONC
and how you'd use it
in the photo shuffler.
And now I want to touch
on another thing
we're introducing,
which we call Partial GET.
So to understand this,
first we have to go
into a little background
on how REST does updates.
So how updating an entry
works in REST
to understand sort of
why things work
they way they do right now
and how we're
gonna change that.
So right now
when you want to do
a read, modify, write cycle,
the first thing you have to do
is get that whole document.
And in REST, each URL
represents a document.
In our case,
they're entries.
But you can think of it
as, you know,
you're updating
an entire document at once.
So you get the entry
you want to update.
In this case,
we're going a GET
on feeds/myfeed/myentry.
The important things
to notice here
are the edit link.
So the edit link has
an additional piece
of information appended to it,
which is a version string.
And that lets us do
optimistic and currency,
which we'll see
in a second.
But we need that--
We need to use that edit link
when we're updating
the entry.
And then it's gonna
have a title,
and then it's gonna have
a bunch of other fields.
And let's say
all we want to do
is change the title.
Unfortunately, we're operating
at the level of documents,
not at the level of XML.
So we actually need to save
all of that stuff,
'cause we're sending entire
documents back and forth.
We're not actually
just sending fields.
So no matter what
that other junk is,
we actually need to keep
track of it unfortunately.
So then once
we have this data,
we need to change the fields
that we actually
want to modify.
So let's say we just want
to change the title
of the favorite picture,
leave everything else alone.
Then we need to put that
back to the server
using that edit link.
So we do a PUT to that link.
You can see that version string
at the end there
with that new title and all
those other fields we had.
We need to include
everything again.
Now unfortunately,
sometimes someone else
may have changed that element
at the same time--
that entry at the same time
you were,
which means the server will
return a 409 conflict.
And it will be
a little bit nice
and return
the new entry for you.
It'll return
that new document.
So you don't have to do a whole
read, modify, write again.
You just do
the modify, write.
But it's still
kind of a pain.
You get that--
You see in this case
the title actually
didn't change,
and that was all
we cared about.
We just wanted
to change the title.
The title didn't change,
but we still need
to go through this whole
conflict resolution.
The edit link changed
because there's a new version
and maybe the summary changed,
but everything else
was the same.
So it's kind of annoying
that we have to go through
all this just to be able
to update a simple field
And the reason
this actually matters
in terms of GETs in general
is all GETs
in the Google Data APIs
need to support update.
So you can't just ask for some
small subset of what you want.
You have to ask
for the whole thing...
until now.
So we're introducing something
we call Partial GET.
And you can't always
get what you want.
But if you try sometimes,
you might get what you need.
Okay, so what
a Partial GET does
is it allows the clients
to actually ask for
exactly what they want
and nothing else,
which is the key part.
So what we did is we added
a query parameter
called the fields
query parameter
that lets you say
exactly what you want.
So in this first case,
you have a feed.
You want the ID, title,
and entries in that feed.
And in the second case--
this is a request
for a particular entry,
not a whole feed of entries--
you just want the ID,
title, the media:group,
and the georss:where.
And this is actually a request
for the add on version
of that entry in that feed.
So those fields
are actually relative
to the Atom names of things.
So there's actually--
It's media:group
because that's what
you'd be getting back
as the name of that field.
And we'll see when we look
at this for JSON,
it actually uses
the JSON names.
So but what if--
What if you actually want
to specify, you know,
that you only want
the IDs and title
of those entries
within that feed?
We allow you to use
a parenthetical notation
to actually request that.
So if you want
the entries in a feed,
and you want just
the media:group,
and in that media:group
you just want
the media thumbnails,
that's how you'd do it.
You'd say entry(media:group
(media:thumbnail)).
And this is only
element level selection,
so there's no
attribute selection.
All attributes
in anything you select
will always come along.
And this was actually
a simplification
to make things
a lot easier.
And it turns out that we have
so few attributes
and they tend
to be so small
that it doesn't really
significantly affect
the size of things.
Here's the second example.
For the entry itself,
you want the author's name.
That leaves
everything else out.
And you want the gml:pos
out of the georss:where.
Leaves everything else out.
So it's pretty simple
to specify
what set of elements
you want.
But there's
one more thing we added,
which is conditional filters.
And this is based--
Well, it's similar to XPath.
It's a very strict subset
of some of the XPath selection
and conditional filtering.
So it lets you actually say
that you want,
in the first case here,
only the thumbnail
whose height URL is 144.
And this will leave--
anything that doesn't match that
will not get sent.
So this is a great way
to select a particular element
out of an array of elements.
And another example is when
you're selecting entries
when you're getting
that feed of entries,
suppose you only
want those entries
that were authored by Sam,
and the server doesn't give you
a way to query that.
We can actually use a filter
after the query
to only get back the ones
that have the name Sam.
The important thing
about this
is that filters
are not queries.
So if you're doing a query
on a feed,
and you're asking
for 100 results,
and then you say
you only want the entries
whose author's name was Sam
and that only matched ten,
you only get ten back,
even if on the server
there were maybe
100 out of 2,000 that matched.
So it's a filter
after the query matches.
So the query matches
the first 100,
and then the filter gets applied
and pares that down.
So it's very important
to remember that.
The other thing to notice here
is in the response
we actually wrap the response
in a gd:partial element,
and we include the fields
that you selected.
And we'll see later--
At the end of the talk,
I'm gonna talk about
some of the new stuff
we're working on after this,
and this comes
into play there.
But it's also
useful for parsers
to know that you're getting
a partial response
and to know, in that case,
that, for example,
some of the entry fields
that usually required--
Like Atom ID is required.
It's actually here.
And feed ID is required,
and it's not here.
Those elements are required,
but they may not show up
because you actually didn't
select them in the partial.
So this is actually
not a valid feed,
but it's
a valid partial feed.
So that's why
that wrap element exists.
Okay, so let's
go ahead and use this
in our Photo Shuffle
application.
It's pretty simple.
That source
that we requested,
we just add this fields=.
And here you see
what I was saying before
about how the JSONC
is actually based
on the JSONC names,
it's not "entry,"
it's "albums."
So you say
I want the albums
and I want their
ID, title, their feed link,
and that was links(feed),
not link with the rel
where, you know,
this long condition, right--
It's much simpler
in this case.
You just want the feed link,
and you want
the media(thumbnails)
and nothing else.
And those are the only things
the application uses,
so that's what we request.
We just ask for what
we actually want
and leave everything else.
And then the only other change
we have to make
is that we now have
that wrapper element,
that gd:partial
wrapper around things.
So rather than having
the feed be the top level,
the wrapper's the top level.
So you have to do
data.feed.albums
rather than data.albums.
But otherwise, everything
else stays the same.
So how does this
affect the size?
In a pretty big way.
We went from our original
770 kilobytes
down to, you know,
I think it was 380ish
for the JSONC.
Now we're down
to I think it was
70 kilobytes uncompressed
in the partial,
because we got rid of all that
other stuff we didn't want.
Even compressed,
it's actually pretty good.
It went from about 38
down to 10.
So it's
a factor of four there.
Really, really makes
a huge difference,
and it affects
the request time.
So it takes about--
it was about two seconds,
a little over two,
rather than taking
almost four for the JSON
and 2 1/2ish for the JSONC.
So the request time's good,
and the parse time
is even better.
There's so much less data
that it's just a lot quicker.
Part of the reason that
the request time didn't drop
as much as you'd expect
is that, of course,
there's a fixed
amount of time
that is going to happen
between your round-trip.
Regardless that's just
your latency,
and then also the server
has to do some work
so that--
that takes up some time.
So the actual
amount of time spent
sending the data
back and forth is smaller.
So the parse time is smaller.
Okay, so that was--
that was Partial GET.
We're very excited about that.
The last thing
I want to talk about
is actually something
that came out a little bit ago
but some of you may not
be familiar with,
which is our ETag support.
So you may have seen this,
and you may not have.
How many of you guys
are familiar with ETags?
Hopefully most of you.
Okay.
Okay, well, I'll go in
a little bit on it,
but again I'm gonna
first do a little background
into sort of why things are
the way they are right now
in our service
and then talk about
what we're doing
in the future.
So our initial service
was based
on the HTTP/1.0 support
for client-side caching,
which uses
the Last-Modified
and If-Modified-Since.
So when you're doing
a Conditional GET,
you want to say, you know,
give me this feed
or give me this entry
if it hasn't changed
since this time.
The way you get that time
is by the Last-Modified
data on the response.
So you'll get back a feed.
One of the headers
will be Last-Modified.
It will have this date.
You record that,
and then when you're doing
your next request
for that feed or entry,
you send that along with it
in a header,
in the If-Modified-Since header.
And then if it hasn't changed,
the server will respond
with a 304 Not Modified.
So this is pretty basic.
It should be 1.0.
It's pretty simple.
You just use a date.
You just send it up.
It tells you if it changed.
But unfortunately, there are
some problems with it.
The biggest problem is that
it has one-second granularity.
So this was kind of
a huge mistake,
especially as things
have gotten faster,
it's pretty easy nowadays
to actually make multiple
updates within a second.
So if you had--
If your time stamp
on your element--
Maybe you have millisecond,
maybe you have nanosecond
granularity in your back-end,
so that will change.
But if it's within
the same second,
the client can actually
think it has the newest version
and not because it changed
twice in the same second.
So that the client
can make a request
halfway through that second
and get it back.
It's pretty rare,
but it does happen,
especially at that scale.
So this is kind
of a problem.
There are some ways
you can fix it.
You can have the server
delay the response
until a second has elapsed.
You could use
days in the future,
except the spec
doesn't allow it.
So there's issues there.
And another problem is that
we're dealing with time,
but at the same time
the server is the only
valid source of that.
So it's really--
It's a time stamp,
but it's actually--
It can't be used
as a time stamp.
You can't, you know,
do date computations.
The server could change dates.
You know, you can't use it
to judge when things change.
It's actually
not useful as time.
And you can't use it
on the client
as if it was actually time.
You have to actually send
exactly what you got back.
You can't, you know--
If something is similar,
you can't take it.
You can't do less thans.
It has to be equal.
So that's kind of a problem.
Okay, so my slides
had a little issue there.
All right,
so how do we fix this?
HTTP/1.1 introduced
something called ETags,
which some of you
are familiar with
but many of you aren't.
They're pretty simple.
They're actually
just an opaque quoted string.
So rather than having a date
that looks like a date
but you can't use it
as a date,
you have to just treat it
as an opaque string.
ETags are an opaque string
to start with,
and they can be much smaller
because of that.
You can encode data in there.
You can encode a lot more
than just time stamps.
You can code whatever
you want.
You can do hashes.
They're just a string
with two quotes.
Very, very simple.
There's one additional
complication.
They may be what's called
strong or weak.
The difference
is that strong ETags
can be used
for conditional updates,
which I'll talk about
in a little bit.
And weak ETags can only
be used for conditional gets,
not for updates.
So here's a weak ETag.
There's just a w/ before it.
Nothing too exciting there.
Just think of them
as opaque strings,
and you'll be fine.
The way it works
is that a server will--
HTTP/1.1 server will respond
with an ETag header
in the response,
and our Google Data APIs
will return that
on our new versions as well
on feed and entry requests.
So here's an example response.
You see the ETag header,
and then there's also
two other things.
So we actually
also return the ETag
at the feed level
and at the entry level.
So when you request a feed,
we'll give you back
the ETag for the feed itself
both in the header
and on the element,
and the reason
it's on the element
is in case you don't
have access to the headers
it's easy to get to.
But we also give you it
on each of the entries.
And that's really useful
because that way
you can use that ETag
for both conditional get
of that entry itself
and conditional update
without having to go back
and make a separate request
for the entry.
So just the feed
gives you all you need.
So how do we actually do our
client-side caching with this?
So instead of using
If-Modified-Since,
which is what we used
to the Last-Modified,
we're gonna use
If-None-Match.
Oops.
I think that was
out of order but--
All right, so--
Yeah, I have a slide
out of order.
Sorry about that.
I'll go back to that
in a second.
Here's what it looks like
with the If-None-Match.
So you send
an If-None-Match request
with that ETag,
either weak or strong.
So in this example
it's for a feed,
so it was weak.
And then if it
has not changed,
the server will respond
with a 304 Not Modified.
And I'll go back to that.
You can see the only thing
to really think about here
is the request time.
On a Not Modified,
the server doesn't send you
any data back.
And in fact,
back-ends can be quicker
to respond
with a Not Modified
than with the full data.
They don't have
to go fetch everything.
They can just see:
Oh, did the version change?
No. Okay, just respond
with the 304.
You're done.
Things are much quicker.
And then on the client,
for example in the browser,
the browser will just
pull that data
out of its local cache.
So you don't have to worry
about the request time.
You don't have to worry
about the bandwidth.
There's no bandwidth used.
Much, much nicer.
Okay, so that was
Conditional GET.
But the other thing
you can use ETags for,
which you couldn't use
the If-Modified-Since for
was--is for
optimistic concurrency.
So rather than using
If-None-Match,
use If-Match.
And that lets you say,
modify this document
or this entry
only if the ETag matches
the one I'm gonna send you.
So here's an example.
We want to put a new version
of some entry.
We give it the URL,
and in this case--
Well, it looks sort of
like the old one,
but in this case
there's actually
no longer a version string
at the end of it.
It's just the entry ID,
so it doesn't change
between versions,
which is very nice.
And you just say,
"If-Match,"
and you give it
the strong ETag,
not the weak ETag.
And if nothing--
If it matched,
if that ETag was okay,
you get a 200 OK.
You successfully
change that entry.
If it didn't, you get
a 412 Precondition Failed,
and again it will
send you back
the new version
of the entry,
so you know what changed,
and you get the new one.
One other thing
you can do with this
that you couldn't do
with the old system
is use If-Match:*.
And what this does
is it allows you
to force an update
even if someone else
has changed
that entry between.
So this is actually
kind of dangerous
unless you're using
something
I'm gonna talk about
at the end of the talk.
But if you're just using
a regular update,
the problem with this
is you'll overwrite
anyone else's changes
without keeping them in,
because you're putting
an entire entry back.
So use with caution.
Okay, so we've seen--
We've seen ETags now.
We know what they are.
How do we actually
add ETag support
to our application?
It's not very complicated.
you just do &v=2
and you're done.
And this is actually
our versioning support, which--
So who's familiar
with the Google Data APIs'
versioning support
that was added?
Okay, only a couple of you.
So you can go look at
the docs,
but basically
we've been rolling out
new versions of services,
and the way we version them
is using
a version parameter, V.
In this case,
the Picasa Web Album's API
is on version two.
And version two
includes ETag support.
So if you want ETags,
you just change to version two,
and there you are.
Okay, that was--
that was ETags.
And now I'm gonna
talk about stuff
that doesn't quite exist yet.
So ETags is already out.
JSONC is on Picasa Web Albums.
Probably this week it will
launch the final version.
I'm actually using a sort of
preview version of it
that's in production,
but it's going to change
a little bit.
And then YouTube
is actually working
on their JSONC support
right now.
So that'll be out soon.
And we're gonna keep rolling out
more services to that.
Partial GET
will actually roll out
a little bit faster
than that.
So as we roll that out,
we'll let you know
on the blogs
and on code.google.com.
So an eye out for that.
But now I'm gonna
look at some stuff
that's not quite there yet.
So it'll be a little bit
farther in the future.
So the first thing
is that JSONC
is not a read only protocol.
We actually meant for this
to be both read and write.
So unlike our existing JSON
where we convert on the server
from XML to JSON,
and then on the client convert
from JSON back to XML
and turn it back to XML,
you can actually send back
the JSONC.
You don't need to translate
back to XML for update.
You can send it directly.
And this supports
all write operations,
including match
and the regular putsand posts.
And one nice thing
is that the new browsers
are actually adding
capabilities for reading
and more importantly writing
in JSON directly,
which makes it much nicer.
You can actually just call
a browser method,
JSON.stringify(data),
and that'll give you
a JSON string
that can be sent to the client,
to the server.
One other thing
we're gonna do
is roll all this
into our client library,
so you won't actually
have to do any of that.
Excuse me.
Another thing
that this gives us
is it lets us
make the client libraries
much, much smaller
than they are right now.
So currently
our client libraries
actually contain a bunch
of data model classes.
So there's, like,
a photo entry class
and a media group class
and all these other
JavaScript objects
with functions and things
to make life easier
basically because
the existing format
was so hard to work with.
It's much nicer to call,
you know,
entry.getmedia:group
than it is to call
entry.media$group
and actually try to do
the XML stuff yourself
and all that.
But of course with JSONC,
it's much nicer.
We don't need all that,
so we can throw that out
and just give you
the bare-bones client library
that does
the interesting stuff,
including, you know,
read-write JSON,
marshaling things
on the wire.
Very importantly, giving you
authentication support.
So giving you auth support
in the client library.
And also giving you
cross-domain support,
so that's the other big thing
that our client library does.
So you can actually do
read-write requests
cross-domain
using our library,
which is very nice.
The other big thing is that
that Partial document
I was talking about,
that gd:partial,
you can actually
send those back to the server.
So Partial
isn't just for GET.
And this is--
this is a huge part
of our goal of making--
making it so you only need
to work with the data
you really, really care about.
So you can get
a partial document,
modify just that field
you want to modify,
and send that back
to the server
using PATCH instead of PUT.
So it's really nice.
And the other thing
it gives you
is that If-Match: *
I was talking about
that was dangerous
is now safe
because you're only
changing the field
that you know the truth
about.
So it doesn't matter if other
people changed other fields.
Like, if the summary changed,
and all you're modifying
is the title,
you can actually do that now.
You can just send the title.
You can send a dif.
Makes it much nicer,
and the client only needs
to store the stuff
it actually cares about.
So you only need to store
those difs.
You don't need to store
all of the entries.
all these fields
you don't know about
or care about.
You just store what you want.
All right, so that's it.
That's the new stuff
we're introducing.
If any of you have questions,
please come up
to the microphones,
because this
is being recorded,
so for the recording
and so everyone can hear you.
[applause]
While you're waiting,
I can shuffle some more stuff.
[laughter]
If it works.
I needed a worker thread
like they had this morning.
There we go.
All right.
Okay.
man: So are you going to
implement a patch for XML too?
Mawson: Yes, so Patch
is going to be both XML,
um, and JSONC based.
man: You said
that you supported
cross-domain rights.
What did you do
to support that?
Mawson: So the existing
JSON library
supports cross-domain rights.
We actually use
some browser tricks
to get data back and forth
between a script running
on our domain and the script
running on your domain.
So those two scripts
communicate,
and then the script
running on our domain
can actually do
a regular XML HTTP request
with the data.
And so that's how
you get cross-domain.
So you marshal it
between domains.
man: Thanks.
Mawson: And all
the information on that
should be on the
code.google.com/apis/gdata site.
man: Okay.
Thank you, sir.
second man:
Uh, hi.
I'm Charlie Wood
from [indistinct].
Are all of these
going to be supported
across all
of the product APIs,
or are they sort of optional
for each product to implement?
Mawson: Excellent question.
So they actually are
somewhat optional,
although we're
pushing very hard
to get every single
product to use them.
The problem is that,
especially for the JSONC,
we're actually customizing it.
And I didn't really go into
too much detail on this,
but we're
customizing the output
specifically
for each product.
So things are gonna look
like you'd expect.
So a photo in Picasa Web
looks like you'd expect
JSON for a photo to look.
And in YouTube,
a video's gonna look
like you'd expect
a video to look.
So that's
a bit more work to do,
so it does take more time,
and it does require
extra effort
on the part
of our services.
So we're pushing on them
to get it done
as quickly as they can, so...
But if you guys
want particular services
to have this support,
you know,
go on their boards
and ask for it,
and that'll give them pressure
to come to us
and ask for help,
so it'll be good.
man: Hi.
Are you going to support
APIs for Google Reader
anytime soon?
Mawson: For what?
man: For Google Reader.
Mawson: Google Reader.
I don't know of any plans
to support any,
but even if I did,
I wouldn't know.
So, yeah,
I don't actually know.
I don't know about that.
Any other questions?
All right, well,
thank you guys for coming.
[applause]